[موسيقى]
هتكلم النهارده عن حاجه جميله جدا اسمها
التراديشنز او التقاليد انا عارفه ان
الكلمه دي كبيره جدا على ان احنا نقولها
في سن صغير كده بس حقيقي لولا ما كنتش
هبقى موجوده بينكم هنا النهارده انا احب
مظهر 24 سنه من اسوان
اول صوره او الناس اللي تعرف اسوان اول
حاجه جت في دماغهم صوره معينه لشخصين ست
لابسه عبايه غامقه ومغطيه وشها
وطبعا مش بتتكلم وراجل لابس جلابيه لونها
غامق عامه
وماسك عصايه
التقاليد هي مجموعه من الافعال اللي
قلدناها نتيجه من جدودنا واهلنا زمان
وللاسف
ما تقبلش لتغيير ولا ان احنا نشكك فيها زي
ممارسات معتقدات سلوك معين
من اكتر الجمل اللي سمعتها زمان وانا
صغيره
انت بنت
ما ينفعش تكملي تعليم ما ينفعش تركبي عجل
ما ينفعش تسافري لوحدك جمل كتير قوي
سمعتها
سالتهم سؤال مهم ساعتها طب ايه اللي ممكن
ينفع فجاوبوا علي انك تتجوزي وتقعدي في
البيت
كان عندي نقطه محتاجه افهمها الاول قبل ما
اعمل اي حاجه هو انا طلبت حاجه اكتر من
حقوقيه هو انتم ليه بتقولوا كده
الفكره عندنا في الصعيد او في اسوان
بالاخص
هي انه التقاليد مقدسه اكتر من الدين بس
نسبه التقييد بتختلف من اسره للتانيه
ولكن كله في الاخر بيخضع لثقافه واحده هي
تميز او تمييز الراجل عن الست وطبعا اي
تفاعل من الست بالنسبه لهم بيبقى شيء
مستنكر
قعدت كده حتى سته ابتدائي بعمل ابحاثي
بيني وبين نفسي
هو ليه ليه كل حاجه لا
سمعت جمله واحده بس طول الوقت
قالوا دي عادات وتقاليد يا رحاب ولازم
محاطمه تنفذيها قلت لهم طب ولو ما حصلش
قالوا لي نبقى انت مش كويسه قعدت لحد فتره
الاعدادي حسيت انك كبرت ولازم اعمل حاجه
اول حاجه عملتها اشتريت عجله وعشان اقدر
اقنع اهلي بحاجه زي كده
قلت لهم اصل احنا ما عندناش اخوات ولاد
وبابا اغلب الوقت في الشغل مين هجيب طلبات
البيت
تاني حاجه
اشتركت في جميع الانشطه المدرسيه وخارج
المدرسه كمان وحضرت معسكر من اكبر معسكرات
الصعيد في محافظه البحر الاحمر وده كان
رعايه وجود وزير التربيه والتعليم السابق
استاذ محمود ابو النصر
اسستم وناهضه للتدخين وحصلت على المركز
الاول في مستوى المحافظه رغم اني بنت حصلت
على الطالبه المثاليه على مستوى المحافظه
سنتين على التوالي 2016 و2017
جت فتره ثانكيو
جت فتره الثانويه العامه وكانت بالنسبه لي
دي
اول حاجه قابلتها فكره علمي وادبي ولا
ادبي بلاش وعلمي اكيد قلت لهم طب لو مش
علمي قالوا لي ابقى تتجوزي وتقعدي في
البيت
اهلي طبعا
ما خدوش رايي مش اي حاجه غير انهم وراحوا
واختاروا علمي
وانا ساعتها ما كنتش عارفه اعمل ايه
بس انا ما رضيتش اقبل بالتغيير ده وجاء في
يوم من الايام سمعت عندنا في الاذاعه
المدرسيه انه اليوم هو اخر يوم لتحديد او
تغيير الشعبه فالى من يرغب التوجه للمكتب
فلان الفلاني حتى نهايه اليوم
ساعتها قلت لازم اعمل حاجه واتحركت فورا
وحاولت لادبي وبما انه البلد عندنا صغيره
جدا وكل الناس عارفه بعض اتصلوا بوالدي
فجاه وعرفوه حاجه زي كده بس هو قال لهم
جمله ممكن اغلبكم ما يبقاش عارفها
قال لهم اللي يقدر يجيلي يقل ودي بالصعيدي
عندنا يعني اللي يتحمل يشيل في نفس
المرحله بتاعه الثانويه العامه دي
قابلت صديقه ليا من الصعيد وعندها نفس
فكره التغيير
عرفتني عن كونسبت جديد في حياتي هو المنح
او السكولر شيبس
طبعا فورا اتوجهت لجوجل سالته وقدمت وعرفت
يعني ايه منح وايه الفرق بين المنحه
والبعثه البعثات
وفورا كنت في ثانويه عامه اخر سنه وقبل
امتحاناتي قدمت الست منح لسفارات مختلفه
اتقبلت رسمي في اربعه بس حبيت ان انا اكمل
في واحده معينه لاسباب ما كانت تابعه
للسفاره الامريكيه ومؤسسه مؤسسه امد ايس
لو حضرتك لو انتم تعرفوها
كنت ساعتها مش عارفه اقنع اهلي ازاي ببعضي
اربع سنين عنهم
وسفري يعني اربع سنين على الاقل وسفري
للقاهره
الحل الوحيد كان ساعتها
ان انا اخدهم من ايديهم
كنت بتعمد احيانا ان انا اخد والدي في بعض
الانشطه والمعسكرات وغيره عشان يشوف
الحاجات اللي احنا مش عايشينها او اللي
احنا مش شايفينها
اخيرا اقنعت اسرتي في السفر وان انا اكمل
في المنحه
بس رغم رفض جميع درجات القرابه الاولى
وسمعت طبعا كلام كتير ما كانش يعجبني
ويخليني حاجه من الاتنين يخليني تعيسه
يخليني مثمره جت فتره الجمع ووصلت القاهره
في اغسطس 2018 كانت برفقه والدي طبعا
استلمت استلمت سكني وقبولي في احدى اكبر
برامج الشراكه في مصر من ثلاث جامعات كان
يونيفرستي واوشن كاونتي وعين شمس
بس برضو ما استسلمتش حصل حاجات كتير بعدها
درست طبعا في التلات جامعات
حصلت على كورسات كتير في الانجلش
كتير قوي رحت معسكرات اكتر لدرجه ان انا
اشتغلت لحد دلوقتي لحد الان في شركه
بتغير افكار ناس كتير في المجتمع والصعيد
بالاخص بس على هيئه معسكرات فبالتالي
سافرت اكتر من 85% من محافظات مصر
اتطوعت كتير جدا اكتر من 4000 ساعه في
اربع سنين
في مؤسسات ومراكز ومستشفيات كتير جدا وكان
اهمهم واللي فرق معي جدا هي مستشفى بهيه
ودوري في الدعم النفسي عندهم
اسيستم مبادره اسمها فيدا بتساعد الاطفال
اللاجئين
ان هم يتعلموا حاجات جديده ايه رايك
وكتابه برمجه رسم كل اللي كانوا بيحبوه بس
ساعتها حصلت حاجه جميله جدا كنت عمري ما
اتخيلها
المبادره دي او
حصلت على المركز ال 17 على مستوى الوطن
العربي وسافرت الكويت
في احدى المؤتمرات
برعايه طبعا وزير الشباب الكويتي كنت اول
مره اسافر بره مصر لوحدي طبعا اتخرجت من
الجامعه بتقدير عام امتياز وحاليا بشتغل
كواليتي قشوره في شركه من اكبر شركات
ومعاملات الماليه والبنوك هي مانيفيلز
طبعا ما اقدرش انسى اهم حاجه كانت بتكرر
طول الوقت وهي اني اتجوز واقعد في البيت
وحقيقي عملتها النهايه اللي عاوزه اقوله
هو من وجهه نظري
لا مش دايما في تقاليد ومعتقدات لولا ما
كنتش اعمل حاجات كتير قوي في دماغي من
اهمها التفاؤل وان يبقى دماغي ناشفه ما لم
اضر حد يعني
التمسك بالاصاله والحدود المتفق عليها من
ناحيه الدين والمجتمع باشمله مش مجموعه
معينه منه بس على الوجه الاخر كان في بعض
التقاليد والمعتقدات اللي كان لازم اتخلص
منها عشان ما اكونش انسان عادي واكون
انسان مميز واعمل حاجات مميزه كتير تفيدني
انا ومجتمعي واسر والاسره بتاعتي بعدين بس
في الاخر الشاطر هو اللي يعمل ماكسنج
بنلتراديشنز عموما ثانكيو
[تصفيق]